all right guys I've got will here with
me will I thought a great place to start
is Bitcoin dominant it seems to just be
exploding higher why is Bitcoin doing so
well compared to everything else yeah
it's been very interesting to see this
over uh kind of the last couple months
you know just for context on what
Bitcoin dominance is this basically
looks at the market capitalization of
Bitcoin relative to the rest of the
crypto market and so as you'll see in
the chart here up on the screen
basically over the last year and
especially over the last couple months
we've seen a really aggressive move up
in Bitcoin dominance and so you know
what is this implicate it basically
means that Bitcoin shown a ton of kind
of relative strength uh to the rest of
the crypto assets and so you know why
exactly is the case uh you know we've
seen somewhat of a kind of General
riskof environment outside of kind of
you know the top call it five or 10 kind
of large large cap tech stocks in the
equities Market haven't seen a ton of
kind of breath across the board just in
general you know some of the
geopolitical uncertainty that we've
recently seen things like this uh you
know perhaps this is the most kind of
bullish uh you know environment for for
you know high-risk assets while at the
same time we've seen this kind of
idiosyncratic bid around Bitcoin uh
primarily uh kind of due to some of the
ETF expectations and and kind of front
running of that um paired with some
people kind of you know expecting a kind
of a pivot point perhaps in kind of the
macro world of of rates kind of peaking
out obviously you know it's yet to be
seen as whether we'll kind of see higher
for longer um but it seems like we've
kind of you know surpassed the kind of
peak uh you know velocity of of raate
hikes and perhaps that's also led to
some of this kind of relative uh
strength for Bitcoin but you know I
think just in general uh you know how
these kind of crypto native Market
Cycles go it's very similar to
inequities where you see kind of high
you know high value deep value assets
kind of you know leading the the charge
off the lows and then over time you you
start to see that kind of liquidity
dispersed into you know higher risk you
know F taale assets same thing in crypto
so typically the way these kind of
Market Cycles move is Bitcoin kind of
leads us off of the lows you know these
bare markets we then kind of see
liquidity disperse into some of these
like you know fat tail uh you know
riskier assets and success saw you know
the 2021 period uh 2017 as well and it
seems like this is you know showing a
very similar pattern as well where
bitcoin's kind shown a ton of relative
strength and kind of led the market off
the lows so not only has it led the
market off the lows but now Bitcoin is
also reclaimed the 200 week and the 200
day moving average does that mean that
the bare Market's over and it's just up
only into the bull market now or should
we look at it some other way yeah so for
people that kind of care more about the
technical analysis Frameworks have kind
of approach ing Bitcoin um one of the
best kind of moving averages to look at
valuation for Bitcoin over the kind of
long term is the 200 we moving average
and so typically the 200 we moving
average has been kind of a level where
bitcoin's bottomed out historically uh
this bare Market was a bit strange
because Bitcoin kind of deviated for a
couple months kind of below that level
so it had a lot of people questioning
whether this time was quote unquote
different uh recently we finally seen
that level kind of reclaimed pretty
decisively as well as the 200 day moving
average uh and then lastly I think also
uh one thing that's noteworthy from kind
of a technical standpoint uh is Bitcoin
essentially traded in this you know 30
to 60k range throughout the entirety of
20121 into 2022 uh 30k was also the
level uh where we saw three arrows go
down so I think you know Bitcoin kind of
reclaiming that is is pretty significant
not only from a technical analysis
standpoint uh but also just from the
sense of you know now Bitcoin is kind of
reclaimed price action uh that you know
was was uh kind of came about because of
the blowup of three errow as well as
Luna uh and then last
of course some of the some of the S SPF
stuff uh I know Luna went down slightly
higher than where we are today but
generally we're around the same area but
three arrows did go go down right around
that that 30k level so I think it's it's
pretty significant just from a uh you
know kind of ideological standpoint as
well as just kind of a technical
analysis standpoint if you were to
survey the market I think most people
would say hey bitcoin's price is going
up because people are speculating on the
ETF um how do you think about the ETF
and its implications or or kind of
impact on bitcoin's price and and is is
it just if the ETF gets approved Bitcoin
goes up is that simple or or is there
some other aspects to evaluate when it
comes to the ETF yeah it's a great
question you know I think it really just
largely depends on the time frame that
you're looking at uh I think in the
short term there's a high likelihood
that the ETF approval itself is probably
short-term kind of sell the news event
that's just typically how these things
seem to go in crypto uh you have a large
kind of front running of these things
and the market sells off um you know
given the kind of the aggression of the
move that we've seen recently you know
if this continues heading into the event
I think there's a higher likelihood the
more aggressive of of the rally into the
event is that there is probably going to
be short-term sell the news but I think
medium to long term uh you know it's
incredibly positive uh you know there's
a tremendous amount of capital
allocators that just frankly can't get
access to BTC because of Regulatory
Compliance reasons or maybe they just
don't feel comfortable uh you know kind
holding their own keys or or trusting a
traditional you know Crypton native kind
of custodial Service uh and so I think
this kind of unlocks the you know all of
that Capital that's that's potentially
interested in allocating to bitcoin but
can't or isn't uh willing to kind of
given of the current infrastructure that
we have in the market so Galaxy digital
actually uh recently released a report
which showed that they're expecting
about $ 35 billion I believe of inflows
within the first year and then something
like 75 billion do in the two to three
years after uh I think one thing that's
that's noteworthy in terms of you know
there's been a lot of Market
commentators that maybe have said um you
know the ETF isn't going to create
demand I think one thing that's worth uh
kind of keeping in mind is uh sure the
ETF itself is just a structured product
um you although it enables you know
perhaps people as as I just described to
allocate to BDC that maybe couldn't
before uh I think the the kind of bigger
the bigger piece is that you know you'll
have uh potentially Black Rock Fidelity
some of these very large tral Financial
organizations that have some of you know
kind of the largest uh you know sales
forces you know advisors um and you know
just like uh you know people that are
kind of discussing with very high level
you know important people throughout the
financial space they're going to be
essentially this kind of mass Salesforce
for Bitcoin we saw you know Larry think
has now gone on television twice in the
last couple months first time called
Bitcoin digital gold this last time
called the recent crypto rally
quotequote flight to Quality uh and so
you know I think that's just kind of a
Prelude to uh what you're going to see
throughout the entire organization of
people trying to push uh individuals to
perhaps you know take half a percent or
1% of their portfolio and allocated to
bitcoin through this new vehicle uh that
they may potentially see approved uh but
you know when you when you're doing at
the scale of of how large some of these
uh you know leading Financial
organizations in the entire world are uh
you know that that could have some
pretty uh large implications for
bitcoin's price now we've got the chart
here of bitcoin's price performance
since the last Cycle's all-time high and
it looks like uh bitcoin's performance
since the 2021 high is generally
tracking in the same way that we've seen
other Cycles track is it just the repeat
of the cycle and having will come and
price goes up how do you think about
this today's episode is brought to you
by trust and will I've gone through a
number of different changes in my life
over the last few years I got married I
had a kid and I had to start thinking
about how could I ensure that my wife
and my child would be okay if anything
ever happened to me that's where trust
wills and estate planning come into play
now most people what they do is they get
introduced to a friend an uncle or
someone in their local community it
tends to be someone who's really
expensive a lawyer an accountant or
somebody who does Estate Planning and
they just simply are using a one- siiz
fits-all template and just telling you
pay me thousands of dollars and I'll use
the same thing for you as the guy down
the street but that's not what trust and
will does they have a trusted online
estate planning product that starts as
low as
$159 which allows you to now protect
your legacy from the comfort of your own
home leverage their excellent customer
support available via phone email or
chat they have thousands of five-star
reviews and a rating of excellent on
trust pilot it takes most people 20 to
30 minutes to complete their estate plan
with trust and will and not only that
but if you go to trustand will.com pomp
you'll get 10 10% off plus you'll get
free shipping of all your estate
planning documents so go to trustand
will.com Pomp and make sure you get an
estate plan in place whether it's for
you or one of your loved ones having a
trust Andor a will can literally be the
difference between someone being taken
care of and someone not go check them
out today at trustand will.com pomp yeah
it's very interesting this is a debate
that's kind of taken place throughout
the crypto Community for a long time um
you know are these Market Cycles driven
by the having uh is it other things that
are just kind of coincidental I think
the reality is the kind of
unboringed important early on uh in
terms of just kind of the impact on
overall supply and demand you know I I
don't think it has a Zero Effect but I
think it's a uh you know much more
minimal effect relative to the prior
couple having I think one way to kind of
illustrate this is if you look at like
the 90-day change in issuance relative
to bitcoin circulating Supply you can
basically kind of see these impulses of
you know how how impactful the having is
we can see that over the last few
maybe it'll you know Ripple out 10 feet
you go in the ocean and do that it's
it's not even going to have an impact at
all and so I think over time um you know
the HS are going to have continued uh
you know diminished effect on the
overall Market uh but on on the flip
side of that I do think uh what's really
interesting and is you know strong
narrative for kind of the market to get
behind uh is Bitcoin stock the flow
ratio will be higher than gold after
this upcoming having and so you know
although we know that Bitcoin is
superior to gold in many ways
portability uh you know transportability
uh divisibility verified ility uh you
know provable scarcity all these types
of things it will be on a stock to flow
ratio basis more scarce than gold which
is you know a very very uh you know
quantifiable metric that that you can
kind of use as a talking point uh and so
I think that in itself is kind of a good
meme or or narrative for the uh for the
market to get behind um and outside of
that I mean what else kind of drives
these Cycles I me the other clear answer
is macro right so if you look at you
know dickin kind of correlation to the
year-over-year change in the dxy if you
look at instance in maret basically
comparing Bitcoin to pmis and basically
kind of tracking it its performance
relative to the economy we can see that
it tracks those things fairly closely as
well and then also you just kind of have
the I think just kind of natural
behavioral dynamics of of uh of crypto
that that are also kind of playing a
factor there as well so I think the
reality is it's you know kind of nuanced
and a combination of these things but as
you mentioned as you'll see in the chart
uh you know this kind of current
performance from from what appears to be
the cycle low so far uh is kind of
reflecting think very similar uh you
know kind of signatures to what we've
seen in in previous crypto Cycles solely
from kind of the time standpoint now one
of the most interesting data points to
me is the supply that has not moved in
at least 10 years is now higher than the
total number of Bitcoin that is on
exchanges is the Bitcoin that has not
moved in 10 years is that just lost
Bitcoin or is there a way for us to
understand no actually these are just
long-term holders who are now you know
holding on to more Bitcoin than the
amount of people who actually have
Bitcoin sitting on an
exchange yeah it's a really interesting
uh point I actually got this uh chart
I'll give a shout out to this guy Jimmy
on uh on Twitter for his last name but
shout out to Jimmy I think this is
really interesting for for a couple
points so what you just described um a
it just shows there's obviously as you
mentioned a large amount of coins that
have been lost uh you know these are
these are in in the chart we're looking
at coins that haven't moved in at least
10 years uh so you know before 2013 uh
so there's probably a fair portion of
that that's frankly lost and the other
piece is of course you know just seeing
a massive amount of belief from
individuals by looking across not just
the amount of Supply that hasn't moved
in at least 10 years but we look at the
amount of Supply that hasn't moved in at
least a year we look at long-term holder
Supply uh long-term holder Supply just
reached an all-time high as a percentage
of overall circulating Supply when we
look at it just outright as just the
number of of coins held by long-term
holders that always just goes up only
but when you look at it more importantly
as a percentage of overall circulating
Supply uh that just crossed an alltime
high of over 76% uh so other words you
know over three out of every four BTC
are held by long-term holders at the
moment which is is pretty incredible uh
you know of course higher prices will in
set of eyes you know new sellers but for
the time being bitcoin's being pretty
tightly held and uh yeah I think the the
metric that we have up on the screen
with with kind of the the amount of
Supply that hasn't moved in at least 10
years relative to the amount of Supply
on exchanges is is just another
reflection of that so I think uh I don't
have it in front of me but I think it's
over 600,000 more BTC haven't moved in
at least 10 years then are on exchanges
so basically you know uh over 6 ,000
more BTC are locked up presumably a fair
portion or lost and you know out of
circulation forever relative to the
amount of of Supply that's currently on
exchanges that's available to be bought
today now the last thing I want to talk
about is this MV rvz score you and I
have been talking about this for years
uh there's basically this Red Zone which
seems to be where uh you know the the
tops of Bowl markets Hit And Then There
are these green zones which seem to be
the bottoms of uh the bare Market uh
during this bare Market seems like you
know this exact same uh Trend played out
and we got into that green zone we went
sideways for a little bit we're now out
of it describe a little bit about mvrv
zcore and and kind of how you use this
to evaluate
Bitcoin yeah so I think uh just to kind
of St take a step back you know one of
the really interesting things that uh
you know kind of the transparency of of
bitcoin's blockchain enables is we're
able to kind of analyze uh the market
and ways that aren't potentially you
know possible with with kind of
traditional equities or other assets and
the reason of course for that again is
it's completely transparent so we can
see all the transactions uh and there's
been a ton of different you know kind of
interesting variations of which you can
do with that ability uh but one of the
most most interesting variations which
is now been around for about five years
now and still in my opinion is is
arguably the the kind of best valuation
metric from a Crypton native standpoint
for for BTC is this mvrv ratio so we'll
kind of break it down exactly uh you
know what is what do the acronym stand
for and and and what does it mean um
it's based on this uh metric called
realiz price so realiz price is
essentially the aggregated cost basis of
the network uh the way this is done is
by looking at the last price that every
every single coin last moved uh and then
you're able to divide that by
circulating Supply and essentially get
this this aggregated cost basis uh and
so when you compare that to what the
current Marshall trading price is of
course you know again price is is set on
the margin right so it's you know
whatever you know buyers and sellers are
are trans acting at today not
necessarily a reflection of what every
person on the planet you know feels like
the value for BTC is at um when we
compare that marginal Uh current trading
price to that realized price we get this
mvrv ratio so it's market value relative
to realized value uh and so uh the kind
of conclusions you're able to come come
to uh with by using this are basically
in the bull market whenever uh you know
you see this ratio get very high
approaching that Red Zone that you
described fundamentally what's that
saying it's saying that uh the kind of
current marginal trading price is
trading at a high multiple to that
aggregated cost basis and so by
definition Market participants are
largely sitting in a large amount of
unrealized profit and so have a high
incentive to want to sell and then
conversely heading back into the be
Market uh whenever we get into the kind
of the the green zone that you described
and this is something that we use in the
back half of the year and kind of called
out basically you know unless these
these metrics are broken this is this is
likely you know somewhat of a bottom
here um essentially what this is showing
is that uh the current maral trading
price is below that aggregated cost
basis so the inverse is by definition uh
the market is underwater in aggregate or
or kind of they're they're in a state of
of unrealized uh losses um so you know
you can kind of use that to say
generally you kind of want to purchase
assets whenever you know the Market's
underwater experien a ton of pain and
there's Force selling Etc and so this is
just kind of one way to kind of to kind
of look at that uh and so I think you
know how do you kind of apply this today
I think you know it's perhaps not super
actionable at the moment but I think
like the one conclusion that you can
take I you know this is best used kind
of on the extremities of of the
valuation uh kind of you know Spectrum
on on on the chart but which you can
kind of come to a conclusion of today is
that Bitcoin is still largely you know
kind of quote unquote underheated or you
know maybe perhaps isn't kind of the
state of like very very uh you know deep
value but still is very far from kind of
overheated uh which is achieved whenever
we see those you know very high
multiples relative to the aggregated
cost
basis now obviously as Bitcoin has risen
there's been quite a bit of excitement
and people kind of uh realize hey maybe
this isn't going away how do you see the
next 12 months or 18 months playing out
in terms of having uh coming up
obviously there there national debt
there's a bunch of these issues that are
all coming together just like given the
information we have today looking out
over the next you know 18 months or so
what is your expectation or what are you
looking for this episode is brought to
you by aradon there are a brand new
startup led by a number of Silicon
Valley Legends who just raised $81
million to build the future of Internet
infrastructure you're probably wondering
what that means let me explain there are
numerous new disruptive technologies
that are being adopted simultaneously
from blockchain to artificial
intelligence to zero knowledge
Technologies in order to ensure that
these Technologies thrive in this new
world we need new infrastructure and
that is where arine comes in they just
launched their first product line called
Tera flux which is a Bitcoin miner
powered by the world's first 4 nanometer
silicon chip technology these air cooled
singlephase and dual phase emerging
cooling miners have unrivaled speed and
efficiency they have Superior uptime and
they leverage a brand new innovation
called Energy tune that allows miners to
dynamically adjust the energy
consumption and Bitcoin hash rate based
on demand response needs of the
electrical grids aradine is an ambitious
company working on hard problems I'm
really impressed with them and if you
want to check out more you can go to
idine.com that's a a d ne.com go check
them out at idine.com today I think of
the most interesting things is um I
track closely on on vlo data which is
one of my favorite data providers um
essentially the kind of tradire uh CME
based data around Bitcoin um primarily
these are moreal financial institutions
that trade on the CME which is why I
think it's interesting to look at
relative to you know a binance or hob or
an FTX or whoever um and when we look at
kind of CME uh Futures activity what
we've seen over the last couple days is
this massive influx and activity both on
open interest for for CME Futures which
reflects the amount of contracts that
are open as well as volume reaching by
far uh the highest that it ever did on a
single day throughout the entire year at
over six billion and the second kind of
highest day throughout the entirety of
2023 was just over four billion uh so
you're clearly seeing kind of interest
from more of these kind of traditional
financial institutions I think this has
also kind of been uh reflected in
looking at basically the uh the
percentage of overall open interest so
if we look at like the open interest
across all the different uh you know
Futures exchanges um all the crypto
natives as well as as CME you see that
CME Futures open uh interest is now
reached an all-time high out of the
overall uh open interest across all the
venues for for BTC I think it's at 26%
25 or 26% um so obviously the fourth uh
so I think this is interesting again
same thing I I just described just
looking at volume out rate um the
percentage of of of open interest uh
drive from the CME reaching an all-time
high basically you know kind of signals
to me that you're seeing on a relative
basis more of these kind of tral
financial institution uh kind of players
kind of Dipping their toes in the water
and so I think you know over the next 12
to 16 months to answer your question you
pair that with with kind of you know the
ETF to to onboard people uh you know I
think this kind of alludes to this idea
that the the kind of makeup of Market
participants in crypto is probably or at
least in Bitcoin uh is is probably going
to look uh pretty different over the
next uh you know one to two years and
beyond that makes a lot of sense tell us
about reflexivity and kind of what you
guys are doing there before let you go
yeah absolutely uh feel free to check us
out at reflexivity research.com we do a
ton of different Deep dive work in
crypto you know 20 30 40 page kind of
deep fundamental research on various
different crypto protocols uh macro
events as well as of course Dynamics
going on bitcoin we just did a Bitcoin
Q3 overview uh last week some of the
information that that we pulled uh for
today it comes from that as well so be
sure to check that out and uh I think
there's there's 20 25 kind of free
reports that we now have on uh on the on
the H page the website that you can kind
of sit through and check us out awesome
I appreciate taking the time to do this
I always learn something every single
time we talk my friend uh we'll
definitely do it again in the future
thanks